for any artist who's watching this
you know about staying out of places
where you're not getting it back like
kind of you know obviously you know
blueface is a great dude yeah when you
when when you're a artist
um you're a business
regardless of what your homies say or
what ever say you're a business you're
everything about you is a business what
you say what you do
you know if he has a car accident it's
not going to be
you know jonathan porter out of carson
it's going to say blueface the rapper
was involved in the car accident
carson has nothing to do with music but
because it's him he's a business
and you're a target you know in this
situation somebody pulled a weapon out
on him i mean they pulled a knife out on
him man had to defend himself you know
what i mean when things started to
happen you know i mean when you seeing
camera footage you only seen a part of
it part of it you know what i mean but
once again it's like that's why i urge
rappers to um keep the proper tools
around you that's going to absorb those
things to where those things happen the
wall is around you to where
they can't really get to you
you know what i mean this is what
security is for i mean you've been that
wall before yeah i'm all i've taken
shout out to stitches
i've taken that hit you know what i mean
i mean that's just me um you know but
unfortunately blueface is young man he
has a life and
i think his struggle with this music
thing is
sometimes he wants to be normal
and i'm trying to get him to understand
is you're not normal as much as you want
to be normal
that's the downside to this [ __ ] he's
also an extremely tall good-looking kid
with tattoos so it's it's not a very
inconsis like it like when he goes out
it's like another one of his downfalls
is is he's genuinely a nice guy yes yeah
so he's not an [ __ ] to where if you
walking up on him he gonna be like hey
get the [ __ ] away from you have people
stop you he genuinely is a nice guy he's
gonna talk have a conversation which
opens him up to more it's very walking
up he's on some [ __ ] right